this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Cornell
and I'm with hi I'm Chris smart I am a
professor of vegetable pathology at
Cornell and today our video is about
diseases of korbit and today we will
talk about korbit jelline disease so
Kenzie what do we have here what's this
plant so this is a squash plant and we
have here um some of the one of the
diseases that we just found um couple of
years ago here at New York we can see
here some of the scorching margins and
um there's also some jello on the leaves
if you can check it out here so this
disease is called Curby Jell-O bind
disease and this bacteria is transmitted
by the squash BG so previously the
squash BG is known as a pet was known as
a pest but it was not known to transmit
any disase creas so I think it's
important to know this because now the
squash book it's a it's a threat to
transmit this disease and we can see
here in the plant we can see some of the
name of the squash book so the squash
book life cycle um it has some uh NES
and then it can become as sadle so we
can also see here some eggs and these
eggs will hatch and will become uh like
these n and you can see here are like
two stages of the NES these are the
smaller ones that are the ones that
hatch and look like this and then they
will become bigger and they will get
this um like grayish color later on they
will uh grow and they will will
becomeing adult and so not all the
squash books can have the can bring the
disease cuz like they have it in their
guts but if one squash bug um have the
disease or have the bacteria in it and
will feed on the plant then the bacteria
probably will um get into the plant and
will the plant will get diseased
eventually so does a squash bug have to
feed on every leaf and is that how the
plant dies or or does the bacteria move
in the plant how does that work so
actually the squash book have to the
squash book fit in every part of the
plant but for the bacteria to be
transmitted it has to Fed in the flowing
of the plant and it doesn't have to feel
fit in every leaf as long as they they
can feed out the um in the stem and uh
mainly the disease will um start the
crown because the bacteria just like can
feed can be in the Flo and this will clo
the flo of the plant and it will create
Yello that we see here so actually what
happens is that since the bacteria is
CLO um clo the flm it will get this
yellow wish because um the nutrients are
not getting into the plant as well as it
will be if the plant will be healthy oh
so it's like you're clogging the veins
of the plant yes yes wow what do we do
about this so the main thing is to
control the squash bug or manage the
squash book because once the bacteria is
in it's hard to control so one of the
main things is getting rid of the squash
book we can do it uh manually maybe
removing some eggs that we see in the
plant or we can also remove the um idles
that we see because the idle can
overwinter so it's important to scout a
field at the beginning of the season to
see if we can see some adles and take
them out of the field and be on the
lookout during the whole season for the
eggs for the nemes and also for the
adults huh so this plant looks to be uh
a pumpkin or winter squash plant um does
it go to to all the squashes does it go
to other cucurbits like melons or or
cucumbers it does so this uh disease can
be seen in zucchini in watermelon in
squash winter squash pumpkin but we have
seen if we plant different um species or
varieties of these ones we will see that
they mostly like um so the squash book
preference is mostly seen in Winter
squat in um zucchinis in acorn squash so
we will probably see that this is more
present in this um varieties or these
cultivar but it also can go to
watermelon maybe if you just have like
watermelon or even cantaloup you will
see that this is there probably too ah
so it depends on which plant the squash
bug likes the best yes so it's mostly
dependent on what the squash book um
like the best cuz as as we said the
squash book is the want the transmit the
disease so the more squash book The the
higher the probability that you will see
that disease in that a specific plant
and once a squash book is start
reproducing you will see like thousands
and thousands of eggs and NES in only
one plant so that will highly increase
the chances for you to get in the
disease wow that's really interesting so
so how does this disease get into the
plant every year like does it does it
live in the soil or or does it come in
on on the seeds that we plant how does
that work so we mostly know that the
squash bug is the one that that uh can
keep that disease in their God so the
squash B will overwinter with the
disease in their God and then with the
bacteria in their God sorry and then
whenever the new season start and the um
adults start coming in the plant they
will be the one that will feed and will
transmit that disease and we will also
see that if we leave some leftovers of
the plant that we are harvesting whether
it's uh pumpkin that might be an
overwinter side too for the squash book
in the bacteria
oh wow so it's really important to to
try to clean your garden or your field
at the end of the season yes it's really
important that you get rid of all the um
let's say all the things that you're not
going to need so you already Harvest and
you have like the leftover plant is
important that we get rid of that so we
make sure that at least we keep the
population of squash boook low and
Kenzie I know you're doing your research
in this area um you know do do you think
that we you'll be able to help the
farmers in the state of New York reduce
the chance of their plants dying from
from this bacteria yes so that's the
idea I'm really excited for this because
I am trying to determine what is the
preference of the squash book and as of
now we are trying to have different
varieties and cultivar to see what is
the most preferred by the squash book
and then we will be working with um
doing some screenings to see if there
are varieties that are like uh
less likely to have a lot of squash BS
and we also want to determine where the
disase is in the state Chris because I
think that's that's very important we
don't know a lot about the disease here
in New York because we just reported uh
the disease this year but we are really
hopeful that we will be able also to
determine or detect the disease because
sometimes it's confused with other um
diseases or people think that they have
like uh nutrient deficiency in their
field but actually what they have is the
disease person but they just don't know
so I think diagnos ICS is one of the
first thing that we have to focus on in
the state right because the symptoms can
be really similar to other things yes
well good luck getting identifying
plants that are more resistant to this
devastating disease thank you so much so
if you want to check out more about
these disease um we will have more
information available in the Cornell uh
vegetable website thank you this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell.edu